♪
>> AMERICAN HELD HOSTAGE,
ABANDONED BEHIND ENEMY LINES BY
DAY 41.
>>Sean: AMERICANS AND THEIR
FAMILIES AND OUR ALLIES IN GREE
CARDHOLDERS ALL REMEMBER
HOPELESSLY ABANDONED BEHIND
ENEMY LINES AND TODAY AFTER
SPENDING MOST OF THE WEEKEND
HIDING, JOE BIDEN FINALLY ISSUE
A PUBLIC STATEMENT AND EVEN
ANSWERED FOUR QUESTIONS, BUT
HE'S PROUD OF HIS WORK IN
AFGHANISTAN.
AND WONDER HOW THE FAMILIES FEEL
, I WONDER HOW THE PEOPLE
CAUGHT BEHIND ENEMY LINES FIELD.
THE REPORTERS WERE ALL
PRESELECTED AS PER USUAL, JOE H
CALLED THEIR NAMES FROM HIS
LITTLE LIST, HE OBVIOUSLY PUT
TOGETHER BY HIS STAFF AND AT NO
POINT DID HE MENTION THE
AMERICANS HE ABANDONED AND LEFT
BEHIND TO SUFFER UNDER THE
TALIBAN THAT HAVE NOW BROUGHT
BACK FOR SHARIA LAW IN THAT
MEANS YES, THE DEATH SQUADS
EXIST, WOMEN AND CHILDREN CAN'T
GO TO SCHOOL, GIRLS CAN GO TO
SCHOOL, WOMEN AND GIRLS THAT IS
NOR DID HE MENTION HIS DRONE
STRIKE THAT KILLED HUMANITARIAN
AND YES, SEVEN CHILDREN N0
TERRORISTS
INSTEAD JOE AGAIN CONGRATULATIN
HIMSELF ON WHAT WAS HIS DEBACLE
OF THE WITHDRAW FROM AFGHANISTA
AND SAYS HE WON'T MAKE APOLOGIE
FOR THE WAY IT ALL WENT DOWN.
PRETTY ARROGANT, JOE PERRY TAKE
A LOOK.
>> THEY'RE IS NO EASY WAY TO EN
THAT AND WE'RE NOW STILL GETTIN
PEOPLE OUT, BUT IT'S REALLY,
THERE IS NO PICTURE BOOK WAY TO
SAY OKAY, LET'S GET EVERYBODY
OUT AND WELL GO HOME.
NO WAR HAS EVER ENDED THAT WAY
OTHER IF IT'S A SURRENDER AND
IT'S A TOTALLY DIFFERENT
CIRCUMSTANCE.
THEY'RE IS A LOT I'M SURE ALONG
THE LINE, BUT THINGS I COULD'VE
DONE BETTER, BUT I MAKE NO
APOLOGIES FOR MY PROPOSALS, HOW
I'M PROCEEDING, AND WHY I THINK
BY THE END OF THE YEAR WERE
GOING TO BE IN A VERY DIFFERENT
PLACE.
>> THERE WAS AN EASY WAY, NO
APOLOGIES.
WHY DIDN'T YOU TAKE OUT WHEN YO
HAD FULL CONTROL OF KABUL AND
THE TALIBAN WAS ONLY BEGINNING
THEIR MARCH AND RUNNING OVER TH
AFGHAN MILITARY THAT YOU BRAG S
MUCH ABOUT IN JULY, WHY DIDN'T
YOU GET AMERICANS AND THEIR
FAMILIES IN GREEN CARDHOLDERS
AND AFGHAN ALLIES AND OUR
MILITARY EQUIPMENT OUT IN MARCH.
WHY DIDN'T YOU DO AND IN APRIL,
MAY, JUNE, JULY WHEN YOU HAD
FULL CONTROL OF KABUL AND COULD
HAVE DONE ALL OF THAT SAFELY AN
GOTTEN EVERYBODY HOME?
YOU SAID YOU WOULDN'T ABANDON
THEM, AND YOU DID.
YOU SHOULD APOLOGIZE FOR THAT,
JOE.
ONLY ONE SMALL PART OF HIS
BIZARRE RAMBLING DEFENSIVE
SPEECH WHERE A VERY IRRITATED
LOOKING JOE BIDEN ATTEMPTED TO
BLAME EVERYBODY, BUT HIMSELF FO
EVERY CRISIS HE CREATED.
HE CAUSED THEM ALL.
THE SCOLDING BORDER PATROL AND
PEOPLE THAT WON'T LISTEN TO HIS
ONE-SIZE-FITS-ALL MEDICINE FROM
A GUY THAT NEVER WENT TOO
MEDICAL SCHOOL AND FRANKLY WAS
HORRIBLE STUDENT ON TOP OF ALL
OF ITS.
FIRST WITH COVID CASES BIKING
ALL AROUND THE COUNTRY, 300
PERCENT HIGHER THAN LAST
YEAR, CONDEMNING EVERY AMERICAN
WHO HAS NOT RECEIVED A COVID 19
VACCINE.
LECTURING THEM.
WHAT ABOUT PEOPLE WITH WHERE
CONDITIONS, JOE?
WHAT ABOUT PEOPLE THEY JUST HAD
COVID AND IT'S RECOMMENDED THEY
NOT GET THE VACCINE WHILE THEIR
ANTIBODY LEVEL IS HIGH?
ACCORDING TO JOE BIDEN, THEY AR
DESTROYING THIS COUNTRY AND NOW
MORE VACCINE MANDATES ARE HEADE
YOUR WAY, THANKS TO JOE.
DR. JOE.
>> THEY ARE CAUSING DAMAGE.
THE UNVACCINATED OVERCROWD OUR
HOSPITALS.
OVERRUNNING EMERGENCY ROOMS AND
INTENSIVE CARE UNITS.
THE UNVACCINATED PUT OUR ECONOM
RECOVERY AT RISK CAUSING UNEASY
ECONOMY AND CAUSING UNEASE
AROUND THE KITCHEN TABLE.
THE REFUSAL HAS CAUSED ALL OF U
THE REFUSAL TO GET VACCINATED
HAS COST ALL OF US.
BY MOVING FORWARD WITH
VACCINATION REQUIREMENTS
WHEREVER I CAN.
>> NY, JOE, ARE YOU CONTROLLING
ALL THE MONOCLONAL ANTIBODIES
AND RATIONING IT CONSIDERING
YOU'VE SHOWN SUCH GREAT SUCCESS
I KNOW YOU ONLY HEARD ABOUT THE
WEEK AND A HALF AGO.
FEDERAL MANDATES ARE NOT ONLY
UNCONSTITUTIONAL, BUT THEY'RE
ALSO DEEPLY UNPOPULAR,
ESPECIALLY IF FOR WHATEVER
REASON I DON'T KNOW, LIKE NEW
YORK CITY, AFRICAN AMERICANS IN
NEW YORK CITY IT'S A LITTLE OVE
30 PERCENT THAT HAVE BEEN
VACCINATED THAT ACCORDING TO JOE
, HE IS FOLLOWING HIS SCIENCE
AND LESS IT INTERFERES WITH HIS
POLITICAL AGENDA.
TODAY WHAT IS BEING CALLED A
BOOST FOR BIDEN'S CAMPAIGN TO
GET A BROAD SEGMENT OF AMERICAN
ACCESS TO BOOSTERS, THE CDC
DIRECTOR SINGLE-HANDEDLY
OVERRULED HER OWN AGENCY THE CD
ADVISORY PANEL TO RECOMMEND
COVID BOOSTER SHOTS FOR A
VARIETY OF AMERICAN WORKERS AND
ACCORDING TO EVEN THE NEW YORK
TIMES, IT'S HIGHLY UNUSUAL THIS
DECISION.
SO WET, POLITICS FIRST AND
SCIENCE SECOND, JOE?
IT'S ALSO HIGHLY UNUSUAL THAT
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
RATIONING THESE THERAPEUTICS
MONOCLONAL ANTIBODY.
IN RED STATES.
NOW THE GOVERNOR WHO ACTUALLY
SET UP CENTERS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF FLORIDA, NOW HE'S HAD
TO GO OUT ON HIS OWN AND BUY
THEM HIMSELF.
JOE NEVER MENTIONED THESE UNTIL
LAST WEEK.
BUT FOR JOE BIDEN, FINDING
SOMEONE TO BLAME FOR HIS
FAILURES IS MORE IMPORTANT THAN
PROTECTING AMERICAN LIVES GREAT
LOOK AT THE BORDER FOR EXAMPLE.
IT DOESN'T TAKE A GENIUS TO
FIGURE OUT THAT IS AN
UNMITIGATED DISASTER OF HIS
MAKING AND HAS BEEN FOR SEVEN
MONTHS.
A REAL CRISIS THAT THEY HAVE
BEEN DENYING.
THOUSANDS OF MIGRANTS BACK
TOGETHER IN HORRIFIC SQUALID
CONDITIONS.
MANY INFECTED WITH COVID 19,
WOMEN AND CHILDREN ARE BEING
TRAFFICKED PHYSICAL AND SEXUAL
ASSAULT IS OCCURRING ON THE
LARGE-SCALE.
VIRTUALLY VIRTUALLY NONE OF THE
MIGRANTS UNDERGO ANY PROPER
VETTING WHATSOEVER.
THEY'RE IS NO COVID 19 TESTING,
AND PEOPLE ARE THEN BEING
RELEASED INTO THE U.S. AND NO
VACCINE MANDATE FOR THEM EITHER.
THIS WEEK ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
ATTACKED PILOTS AND ICE
OFFICIALS ON MULTIPLE TRANSPORT
FLIGHTS.
CLEARLY HEALTH AND BACKGROUND
CHECKS ARE VERY IMPORTANT, BUT
ACCORDING TO JOE BIDEN, THE REA
CRISIS, HE'S GOING AFTER BORDER
PATROL AGENTS IN THEIR HORSES.
THEY ARE FIGHTING BACK FIERCELY
SAYING THIS IS ALL A LIE, BUT
HERE IS WHAT JOE IS SAYING.
>> WE SAW AT THE BORDER THIS
WEEK, HOW DO YOU FAILED IN THIS
PROMISE AND THIS IS HAPPENING
UNDER YOU, DO YOU TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE CHAOS?
>> PEOPLE SHOULD BE TREATED LIK
THEY DID WERE.
IT'S OUTRAGEOUS, I PROMISE YOU
THOSE PEOPLE WILL PAY.
THEY WILL BE AN INVESTIGATION
UNDERWAY NOW AND THERE WILL BE
CONSEQUENCES.
THEY'RE WILL BE CONSEQUENCES.
IT'S AN EMBARRASSMENT, BUT IT'S
BEYOND AN EMBARRASSMENT, IT'S
DANGEROUS, IT'S WRONG, IT SENDS
THE WRONG MESSAGE AROUND THE
WORLD, IT SENDS THE WRONG
MESSAGE AT HOME.
IT SIMPLY NOT WHO WE ARE.
>> JOE, YOU CAUSED THIS DISASTER
.
YOU ENDED THIS DAY IN MEXICO
POLICY.
IT WAS WORKING.
YOU STOPPED ORDER WHILE
CONSTRUCTION, IT WAS WORKING.
YOU NOT ONLY BROUGHT BACK CATCH
AND RELEASE, YOU ARE RESPONSIBLE
, YOU BOTH INVITED
PEOPLE TO COME.
THOSE PEOPLE WILL PAY, I GUESS
FORGET ABOUT DUE PROCESS OR THE
PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE, WHAT
ABOUT THE PEOPLE THAT ORDERED
THE DRONE STRIKE, JOE, OH, THAT
WOULD BE YOU, THE ONE THAT
KILLED SEVEN INNOCENT CHILDREN
AND HUMANITARIAN WORKERS.
WHAT ABOUT THE PEOPLE WHO
PLANNED THE BOTCHED WITHDRAWAL
FROM AFGHANISTAN THAT RESULTED
IN 13 DEAD AMERICAN SOLDIERS
TRAPPING HUNDREDS OF OUR FELLOW
AMERICANS BEHIND ENEMY LINES?
WHAT ABOUT THE PEOPLE THAT YOU
ABANDONED IT IN AFGHANISTAN THA
HAVE GREEN CARDS ARE AFGHAN
ALLIES, ALL OF OUR FAMILIES.
WHAT ABOUT THE PEOPLE THAT
CAUSED THIS BORDER CRISIS AND
TOLD THESE MIGRANTS TO SURGE TH
BORDER.
ACCORDING TO JOE BIDEN, HIS
TWISTED LOGIC, A BORDER PATROL
AGENTS ON HORSEBACK WITH A LONG
RAIN IS EVIL, BUT LEAVING
THOUSANDS OF AMERICANS AND OUR
ALLIES BEHIND IN AFGHANISTAN,
THAT WILL BE TORTURED AND MANY
KILLED BY THE TALIBAN THAT ARE
VERY PROFESSIONAL AND
BUSINESSLIKE AS HE QUOTE TURNS
THE PAGE.
THAT'S A SUCCESS?
MAKE NO MISTAKE, AMERICAN
ENEMIES ARE ALL WATCHING.
ALL OF OUR ENEMIES KNOW, CHINA
KNOWS, RUSSIAN NOSE, AT THAT
URANIAN MULLAHS NO, THEY KNOW
THAT HE IS A COGNITIVE MASS AND
WEAK, FRAIL, AND INCOMPETENCE O
NEARLY EVERY MAJOR ISSUE.
THEY DON'T RESPECT AND THEY
DON'T FEAR JOE BIDEN.
CHINA FOR EXAMPLE, THEY HAVE
BEEN CIRCLING TAIWAN WHERE THEY
PLAN THEIR REUNIFICATION WITH
FIGHTER JETS.
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO, JOE?
YESTERDAY THE PEOPLE'S REPUBLIC
OF CHINA, THEY SENT 19 JETS AND
TODAY THEY SEND 24.
THEY KNOW YOU ARE TOO WEAK AND
SPINELESS AND YOU WON'T LIFT A
FINGER, WILL YOU, JOE.
YOU WILL ABANDON TAIWAN JUST AS
YOU ABANDONED THE PEOPLE IN
AFGHANISTAN, YOUR OWN CITIZENS.
JOE BIDEN HAS HARSHER RHETORIC
FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THAN HE
DOES FOR THE COMMUNIST PARTY OF
CHINA.
PROBABLY CHINA HAS COMPROMISING
STUFF ON HUNTER.
JOE BIDEN NOW LIKES TO LECTURE
AND SCHOOLED AMERICANS FOR NOT
PEERING YOUR FAIR SHARE IN TAXES
, WHICH IS IRONIC.
I WILL EXPLAIN.
>> HEY, STEP UP.
STEP UP AND PAY LIKE EVERYBODY
ELSE DOES.
LOOK I REALLY MEAN THIS.
MY WHOLE CAREER, AND I COME FRO
THE CORPORATE STATE OF AMERICA.
I THINK IT'S ABOUT JUST PAYING
YOUR SHARE SHARE.
>> PAY YOUR FAIR SHARE.
OKAY, JOE.
HOW ABOUT THIS, JOE.
HOW ABOUT YOU AND HUNTER, WHY
DON'T YOU BOTH START PAYING YOU
FAIR SHARE AND YOUR TAXES BEFOR
LECTURING THE REST OF US AND
KEEP IN MIND HUNTER, YOUR SON,
THAT'S RIGHT, THE GUY THAT USED
CRACK THAT'S PROBABLY
COMPROMISED BY RUSSIA AND CHINA
AND KAZAKHSTAN AND UKRAINE, AND
LIBYA, HE'S UNDER FEDERAL
INVESTIGATION.
WHY?
INTERNATIONAL TAX EVASION AND
MONEY LAUNDERING.
TONIGHT ACCORDING TO THE
CONGRESSIONAL RESEARCH SERVICE,
NONPARTISAN, JOE, YOU YOURSELF,
UP TO A HALF MILLION DOLLARS IN
BACK TAXES GREAT I WONDER IF TH
AG IN DELAWARE IS GOING TO GO
AFTER YOU LIKE THEY ARE DOING T
DONALD TRUMP IN NEW YORK?
FOR THE EXACT SAME QUOTE
ALLEGATION.
CBC, MSNBC, CNN, MAYBE YOU
SHOULD BE SPECULATING ABOUT JAI
TIME LIKE YOU DO WITH EVERYTHIN
DONALD TRUMP OR DOES JOE JUST
GET THE PRESIDENTIAL PROTECTION
PROGRAM LIKE HE HA